bonjour ça faisait un petit moment
depuis dernier chronique de profs alors
pour ce retour on va faire quelque chose
d'exceptionnel
on va parler exclusivement du 20e siècle
intérieurement je suis un joueur
et pourquoi ne pas en avoir parlé plus
tôt me direz vous vous m'avez déjà
suggéré en commentaire des sujets qui se
rapprochait de cette période mais je
suis médiéviste de formation à la base
et de toutes les périodes historiques
l'histoire contemporaine c'est un petit
peu ce qui m'attire l'eau -
habituellement
et ouais 1 point pour le moyen-âge mais
là il y avait ce petit sujet qui me
trottait dans la tête depuis un moment
et auquel j'ai décidé de m'intéresser
l'aéropostale dit plutôt que la cyber
historienne a commandé un épisode dessus
si vous n'avez pas compris la réplique
précédentes je vous invite à regarder
time warp et la web série de fiction que
j'ai écrite et qui est disponible sur
cette chaîne et sans plus attendre en
voulons nous
[Musique]
tout commence durant la première guerre
mondiale dans les usines de pierre
georges latécoère
il s'agit d'un industriel toulousain qui
possède pas mal d usines qui produisent
entre autres du matériel de cantine voie
ferrée du bois et ses efforts de guerre
oblige le ministère de l'armement lui
demande de reconvertir ses usines pour
produire des munitions et des obus en
1917 on lui passe commande de 1000
avions samsung doit alors qu'ils
n'avaient jamais vu d'avion de près de
sa vie ils démarchent des experts il
fait agrandir ses locaux où il est super
motivé les premiers modèles sont prêts à
être livrés en octobre 1918 mais un mois
plus tard patatras
la guerre est terminée bon ça c'est
plutôt positif en fait et surtout ça
n'arrête pas latécoère qui est des
terres c'est décidé il veut faire
carrière dans l'aéronautique et a déjà
une idée de reconversion une ligne de
transport de courrier et de passagers
son initiative n'est pas nouvelle
nouvelle le ser mais il existe déjà et
l'italie et l'autriche ont déjà des
lignes de transport de courrier par
avion
même si ce sont des lignes uniquement
européenne latécoère a un parcours bien
précis en tête
le maroc ou 80000 européens sont
installés grâce à la colonisation
l'afrique australe et l'amérique du sud
toutes ces destinations échanges déjà
pas mal de courriers avec l'europe à
cette époque mais selon des délais très
longs
sept à onze jours pour le maroc 17 jours
pour le brésil 23 pour l'argentine c'est
pas hyper rapide
ce n'est pas le pérou dès le 11 novembre
ce qu'il a vraiment pas le temps
latécoère dépose des statuts de la sema
en compagnie espagne maroc algérie dès
lors il étudie les routes possibles
réadapte les simpson qui l'avait
fabriqué pour leur nouvel emploi et
surtout se lance dans une bataille
administrative avec la france et surtout
avec l'espagne n'est pas très emballé à
l'idée se faire survoler le premier vol
vers barcelone a lieu le 25 décembre
1918 puis après quelques échecs il
atterrit le 8 mars 1919 à rabat et offre
au maréchal lyautey qui dirige le
protectorat du maroc un journal daté de
la veille et un bouquet de violettes de
toulouse pour sa femme parce que ça
montre qu'il est rapide malin c'est un
gros succès le général y est né et
encourage secrétariat d'état à
l'aéronautique a signé le contrat avec
latécoère à partir du 1er septembre 1919
les lignes latécoère doivent effectuer
huit volent mensuel entre toulouse et
rabat avec un surcoût de 1,25 franc par
courrier en 1919 l'aviation et populaire
les aviateurs se sont battus et sont
reconnus pour leurs exploits durant la
guerre
mais peu envisage un avenir pour
l'aviation maintenant que la paix est
revenue le civil ou le commercial ou
golf
les avions sont encore trop peu fiable
et tombent souvent en panne la france
possède le plus grand parc volant avec
environ 2000 avion mais l'heure est
plutôt aux exploits des pilotes font des
cascades bat des records etc
latécoère recrute justement des pilotes
pour son nouveau projet parmi eux on
trouve didier daurat un ancien
combattant super motivé la compagnie
fait aussi ses premières victimes
six pilotes se trouvent la mort en 1920
cinq autres en 1921 et une trentaine
d'appareils sont déjà endommagés à cette
date
pendant longtemps les équipements
restent sommaires les instruments de
mesure ne sont pas fiables
le premier vol avec radio à lui en 1923
mais elle ne se généralise que bien plus
tard la ligne coûtent aussi plus cher
que ce qu'elles rapportent mais
latécoère reste motivé il rebaptise son
entreprise cgea pour compagnie générale
d'entreprises aéronautiques
mais doit vendre au passage quelques
autres de ses usines pour rentrer dans
ses frais il cherche à produire un
nouvel avion plus performants et se
penche sur son nouvel objectif
l'afrique australe ils recrutent pour
cela le pilote joseph rouag et l'envoie
en bateau en 1923 pour une mission de
reconnaissance entre le maroc et dakar
pour cela il doit tisser des liens avec
deux enclaves espagnoles qui pourraient
devenir des aéro place d'étape cap juby
et villa cisneros la distance totale
entre casablanca et dakar et de 2007 160
kilomètres avec des étapes de 600 km de
long une mission aérienne a lieu en mai
1923 de des avions échoué celui de rouag
atterri à dakar après 22 heures de vol
mais niveau problèmes techniques et
géopolitique s'est toujours pas gagné le
bilan de l'aéropostale en 1923 et
pourtant pas mal un aller retour
quotidiens entre toulouse et casablanca
une nouvelle bretelle vers oran 1344
passagers embarqués et 3 millions de
lettres des millions charmante et vous
voyez ce que ça fait déjà un million
armina en 1925 la ligne casablanca
rouvre enfin et pour cela est affecté un
nouveau pilote qui devient vite une
légende jean mermoz
jean mermoz obtient son brevet de pilote
en 1920 après trois tentatives
une première où il se fracture la
mâchoire et la jambe une deuxième deux
jours plus tard son avion se retourne à
l'atterrissage et la troisième enfin qui
est la bonne il est ensuite affecté en
tant que militaire à palmyre où il
réalise son premier coup d'éclat
après que le moteur de son avion et pris
feu et traverse le désert pendant quatre
jours en portant son mécanicien sur ses
épaules
bad ass pourtant une fois à
l'aéropostale le cas décrit sa vie
simplement nous accomplissons simplement
un métier parfois un peu plus dur que
les autres mais qui n'en n'est pas moins
un métier en 1926 une autre figure
célèbre rejoint la ligne
antoine de saint-exupéry affecté à
l'aéro place de cap juby en 1927 il
passe 18 mois là-bas se baladant dans le
désert à la rencontre des morts et se
liant d'amitié avec jean mermoz qui fait
étape chez lui à chaque vol le boulot
reste dur pour les pilotes
les pannes sont fréquentes qu'elles
entraînent même le risque de se faire
capturer par des tribus mort de la
région la ligne vers dakar est ouverte
il est donc temps pour latécoère de
penser plus loin dès 1924 il commande
une reconnaissance vers le brésil
l'uruguay et l'argentine
il s'allie avec l'industriel bouilhou la
faune pour mener à bien son projet le
défi est avant tout technique
il s'agit de traverser les andes avec
des appareils à peine assez performant
pour ça le latin 26 et mis en service en
1927 et permettent d'envisager la chose
c'est guillaume est un nouveau pilote
qui devient le principal artisan de la
ligne des andes qui tente le coup en
1928 il réussit son premier vol dans la
nuit du 16 au 17 avril mais les journaux
considèrent alors qu'il a juste eu de la
chance
puis il réussit de nouveau pendant une
tempête mermoz se dit alors qu'il
tenterait bien la chose en passant par
le nord il décolle le 2 mars 1929 avec
son mécanicien collenot et le pilote de
l'avion
pas de bol le moteur s'arrête il se pose
sur une plateforme à 1500 mètres et
mermoz est obligé de sauter de l'avion
et de s'accrocher et non pour freiner
l'appareil qui était en train de tomber
dans le vide
sauf que l'avion perd de l'altitude on
fonce sur les arbres et je n'aurai pas
le temps de sortir des trains
d'atterrissage à goa d'hiver ce qui va
ce que je suis ensuite après 1h30 de
réparation ils n'ont plus qu'à remonter
l'avion tout le long de la pente avant
de le lancer dans le vide et repartir
aux dates chef forte au maillot date le
9 mars il retente le coup avec collenot
et c'est encore pire
l'avion devient incontrôlable alors
qu'il tente de passer un col et s'écrase
sur des rochers comme il ne semble pas
réparable comme nous et mermoz décide de
partir à pied par -20° dans la montagne
mais ils font vite demi tour en se
rendant compte qu'ils ont assez peu de
chances de survie il retourne donc à
l'avion et passent environ 50 heures à
réparer à coups de morceaux de chiffons
de fil de fer et de bouts de scotch
il leur faut ensuite plusieurs heures
pour remonter l'avion en haut de la
pente le lancer dans le vide
le faire rebondir sur les trois
plateformes qui prolonge la piste et
enfin atterrir au chili
leur exploit fait de mermoz un héros de
l'aviation il montre ensuite le chemin
un gliome et qui assure la liaison
hebdomadaire à partir du 15 juillet 1929
saint-exupéry est envoyé en amérique du
sud la même année le groupe de pilotes
s'installe à buenos aires pour quelques
années et d'exploits à l'ordinaire
l'aéropostale fonctionne il faut
désormais quatre jours et demi pour
qu'un courrier passe de la france au
chili ce que nous avons fait de brighi
millet et moi d'autres le feront bientôt
nous eûmes simplement l'honneur d'être
les premiers désigné pour mener à bien
cette tentative
nous n'avons fait que parcourir une des
étapes de l'anim europe amérique du sud
guillaume et réalisé un autre exploit en
1930 il décolle le vendredi 13 juin pour
son trajet habituel mais le temps est
mauvais il est contraint d'atterrir au
milieu des ans des pass deux jours sur
place en attendant que la tempête se
calme
le dimanche la viande de recherche
envoyé pour le retrouver ne le voit pas
il écrit alors sur le fuselage de son
appareil
n'ayant pas été repéré par l'avion je
pars vers l'est a dû à tous ma dernière
pensée sera pour ma femme
du dimanche au jeudi et marche à travers
des andes et la neige rapidement pieds
nus il parcourt 60 km avant d'être
retrouvée près de mendoza en argentine
en 1930 l'aéropostale transporte plus de
300 voyageurs entre la france et
l'argentine réalise 27 millions de
francs de recettes et expédie de 32
millions de lettres elle s'effondre
l'année suivante à la suite du krach
boursier de 1929 elle est mise en
liquidation judiciaire même si les vols
continuent et racheté en 1933 par air
france le matériel est moins bien
entretenus
les anciens avions sont envoyés à la
casse les pilotes aussi oui des pilotes
qui ont fait la légende de la ligne
disparaissent collenot le premier le 10
février 1936 mermoz dit de lui comme on
aurait dû disparaître qu'avec moi la
fatalité n'a pas été juste en divisant
cet équipage guillaume et vais
démissionner mais ça lui est refusée
mermoz s'engage dans les croix de feu un
mouvement nationaliste proche du
fascisme bien que saint-exupéry tente de
l'en dissuader
il disparaît également en vol le 7
décembre 1936 la seconde guerre mondiale
à raison des deux autres
guillemet le dessus en 1940 lors d'un
vol marseille beyrouth saint-exupéry
tombe au large de marseille en 1944 son
avion a été retrouvé en 2003 pourquoi
nous l'aimons notre ligne disait
guillaume et c'est parce qu'elle vit
elle vit de tout ce que nous lui avons
donné de nous même quand elle a débuté
nous étions 18 jeunes voué à son succès
de toute notre âme de ses 18 nous sommes
quarante aujourd'hui et tous ceux qui
manquent sont morts à leur poste en
pleine lutte pour que la ligne vive
vous comprenez bien que pour nous leurs
voix ne se sont pas tus elle commande
merci d'avoir regarder cet épisode si
vous l'avez apprécié vous pouvez
toujours le partager et le commenter ou
faire un don sur tipi ou you type qui
sont les deux plateformes qui me
permettent de financer mes vidéos
je vais essayer de retrouver un rythme
un peu plus soutenue en 2020 par rapport
à cette fin d'année 2010 9
alors en attendant la prochaine vidéo
merci d'être toujours plus nombreux sur
cette chaîne et à bientôt arborer bas
comme fin
reynders avant les vacances au cinéma
comme fort c'est bien sa bien-aimée
faire la vidéo
oui oui oui j'apprécie ce félin à l'état
brave bête